[Musique]
indignant jean louis xavier né le 11
décembre 1930 à piolenc vaucluse
artistes dramatiques marié bon père bon
mari bon pied bon oeil
bonneuil pas terrible jean louis
trintignant est ce que vous considérez
aujourd'hui à 40 après le nombre de
films cause à effet comme une vedette
non je ne considère non pas dans leur
encore moins considère comme un étudiant
parce que c'est mauvais esprits parce
que si j'étais plus étudiant ça ne
m'intéresserait plus étudiée quoi
j'étudie l'art dramatique toujours que
je voudrais depuis combien d'années
maintenant moi il faut 20 ans là où
d'autres maîtres de trois ans à
comprendre des choses
moi je suis très très lent je commence à
peine à devenir à devenir pas mal
maintenant mais j'ai été très long
j'étais un très mauvais comédiens
pendant des années j'ai commencé à jouer
mais je ne méritais pas j'étais très
mauvais
j'ai jamais eu vraiment de vocation
d'acteur non j'ai quand j'étais enfant
je ne disais pas quand je serai grand je
serai acteurs mais à l'âge de 15 16 ans
n'ont aucun sens si j'avais envie de
faire un métier artistique mais j'étais
les quartiles particulièrement mais
j'étais tentée davantage par la
sculpture j'aurais voulu être sculpteur
trouve c'est beau on travaille avec ses
mains aurait voulu être peintre musicien
mais j'étais pas doué pour la musique
j'étais pas doué pour la peinture
alors je
j'ai fait je suis devenu acteur parce
que c'est ce qu'il y a peut-être de plus
facile
je ne rêve pas de jouer un rôle
extraordinaire au cinéma ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de faire des films
avec des gens qui m'intéresse mais pas
du tout par rapport à un rôle je choisis
les films que je fais par rapport à un
metteur en scène par rapport à un sujet
mais pas du tout par rapport à un
personnage je veux jouer des très
mauvais rôle ça ne fait rien dans un
film qui m'intéresse même des rôles
antipathique même des rôles antipathique
oui et jusqu'à présent vous n'aviez pas
joué vous avez rarement joué de rôle
antipathique anti quelques-uns c'est en
général ça a moins bien marché de quand
j'ai joué des rôles sympathique n'est
pas parfois tentée dans la vie
l'exercice est méchancetés sur vos
proches sur votre femme par exemple
absolument pas non je suis un mari idéal
j'ai un mari extraordinaire enfin bull
dira non avérées je suis un mari parfait
non je suis j'ai fait un culte
d'ailleurs 2
de la réussite matrimoniale j'ai fait
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi là dessus et ça
m'intéresse beaucoup d'être un mari
parfait c'est sincère sous nos années
vous le diront dans tous nos amis vous
le diront on est un couple assez assez
exceptionnel volontairement ou
naturellement c'est pas naturel il faut
avoir réfléchi faut faire un effort
chacun de son côté et on y arrive après
plusieurs années et après des choses qui
nous sont arrivées mais c'est pas
naturel en ahl jamais été comme ça au
départ et puis c'est une recherche sont
des exigences il faut chaque matin se
réveiller en se disant voilà c'est pas
sûr qu'on va finir la journée ensemble
et nous ça fait 13 ans qu'on vit
ensemble et depuis 13 ans chaque matin
on se remet en question remet notre
couple en question
jusqu'à maintenant on a fini la journée
ensemble depuis 13 ans je n'ai pas ri de
fatigue
ah ouais mais c'est pas facile mais il
faut mais c'est un peu fatigant il a
quelquefois des politiques sont un peu
agaçante par exemple il est de bonne foi
et de vivre avec un teint de bonne foi
ça m'a obligé moi aussi à l'être
totalement parce qu'on peut pas être de
mauvaise foi envers quelqu'un qui
reconnaît ses torts on peut pas soi même
alors c'est pas très pratique pourtant
par quelques rares exceptions les couple
de comédiens ne sont guère en réussite
j'ai peut-être la chance que ma femme ne
soit pas comédienne et qu'elle fasse en
même temps le même métier que moi sans
être comédienne
c'est à dire que les metteurs en scène
notre métier pour nous est très très
important et c'est formidable parce
qu'on parle énormément de notre métier
mais elle en parle d'un point de vue
metteur en scène moins d'un point de vue
comédien c'est à dire qu'on ne se fait
pas du tort au contraire en transition
pardon il n'y a pas d'opposition au pas
du tout non au contraire on s'enrichit
il ne pense pas car hier il est pas du
tout cas botha il est pas du tout quand
il fait un succès quand il a eu le prix
à cannes moi j'étais dix fois plus
heureuse que lui j'étais folle de
bonheur et lui me disait coûts de garde
la distance quand même
n'exagérons pas à l'importance de tout
ça est quand même pas il
il a une vue des choses beaucoup plus
juste d'ailleurs beaucoup plus
généreuse que moi et soudée jaloux non
pas du tout du tout non c'est on peut
pas être généreux et jaloux
non je l'étais mais j'ai travaillé pour
ne plus l'être en laye d'instinct
d'instinct tout le monde est jaloux les
animaux sont jaloux les enfants sont
jaloux on l'est à force de réflexion de
travail sur soi même vous pensez votre
foyer réussi oui oui j'ai j'attache
beaucoup d'importance à sable le voyez
dans son ensemble avec les enfants oui
bien sûr bien sûr et des quand vous
tournez à l'étranger jean zen mais si
votre femme
non non non j'emmène et les enfants vous
savez non jeunes gens mais nos six
enfants et et l'école et bien je suis
organisé pour que le sud des cours par
correspondance et à paris et c'est sur
l'école n'est chili pour par
correspondance aussi c'est à dire que
délibérément vous avait soustrait votre
enfant à l'école uniquement pour les
garder avec vous et avoir la possibilité
de l'emmener oui c'est très important
c'est très important pour moi c'est très
important pour mon enfant aussi c'est
très important pour ma femme il a des
rapports merveilleux avec sa fille la
preuve c'est qu'on l'a emmené voir pau
d'asnières et qu'elle n'a pas compris
pourquoi peau d'âne n'a pas épousé le
roi son père alors c'est vous dire à
quel point il a des bons rapports
et
à
votre famille c'est votre femme votre
enfant et la famille de votre femme
oui les marques en sont des gens et
c'est assez extraordinaire qui m'ont
apporté beaucoup
il n'aimait pas les repas de famille
parce que ça faisait beaucoup de bruit
ça fait beaucoup de bruit les repas de
famille oui puis maman et le bruit maman
la risée bonjour mon petit présent
lorsque je sentais pas diminué pour
autant
là aussi si jamais senti du mieux mais
en plein le début c'est petit à petit on
s'est attaché à lui comme c'était très
très difficile
genouilly je connais jean louis depuis
15 ans et finalement je suis devenu ami
avec lui 2 on y croit nous c'est une
réserve il ne se lit pas facilement il
très difficile et très divisée il a très
peu d'amis
le blizzard on est devenus amis
forcément à la langue puis à la longue
une considère un peu comme un petit pas
par a
non c'est à dire un peu comme un type
qui ne sort pas comme un moine mais
respecte ça je m'enferme parce que j'ai
besoin de cette solitude je reste comme
ça enfermé pendant deux jours deux jours
une nuit je reste enfermé comme
magnétophone et des textes et je
travaille mais je ne sors pas de ça je
ne répond pas au téléphone je ne fais
rien c'est comme si c'était un temps
mort dans ma vie c'est comme si j'étais
malade pendant deux jours je suis malade
là au moins j'ai mon petit coin secret à
moi j'écris des histoires pour le cinéma
j'ai ça et la poésie j'écris pas de la
poésie mais je lis beaucoup de poésie
j'enregistre de la poésie qui entend ça
qui est personnes - votre femme oui des
fois oui oui monsieur surtout pour moi
je travaille je corrige je recommence il
ya par exemple des poèmes que j'ai
enregistré plus de 800 fois les effacer
ça me plaît pas je perfectionne un petit
peu ce que j'ai le plus travaillé c'est
le voyage de baudelaire le bateau ivre
de rimbaud
la prose du transsibérien de cendrars
vous avez un acteur est toujours un peu
un peu insatisfait et là vraiment je
voudrais arriver à une sorte de
perfection si c'est possible mais c'est
peut-être la seule chose finalement dans
mon métier que je rêve que j'aurais
essayé de faire parfaitement je sors de
là très enrichi ça m'apporte ces moments
difficiles à obtenir à notre époque et
et qu'il faut préserver je tiens
absolument à voir ces moments là c'est
ma nourriture est une sorte de moine
comédiens étudiants mois le comédien et
étudiants - le comédien
non je pense que la chose importante
pour un acteur c'est sale nourriture
intérieur et c'est pour ça que
ma famille ça fait partie de ma
nourriture intérieur et j'en ai besoin
je la transporte avec moi
[Musique]